salut après un an et demi de vidéos de
spectacles et d'écriture de livres j'ai
décidé de faire une pause cet été pour
me reposer oui mais aussi pour vous
préparer une renaissance de la chaîne en
septembre vous est demandé sur twitter
si vous vouliez quelques facteurs rapide
et divertissant en attendant alors
pendant ces 60 jours de pause je vous
laisse une vidéo rapide et sans
prétention tous les jours pairs à 11
heures on se retrouve à la rentrée et
tout de suite ça lui alors aujourd'hui
on va parler d'une autre expression la
deuxième de l'été je vous ai dit qu'on
n'en fera 4 cet été sans faire
concurrence à jonathan du tattoo
évidemment mais j'aimerais qu'on
s'arrête quelques minutes sur
l'expression s'en bat l'oeil qu'on
utilise d'ailleurs un petit peu moins on
s'en bat autre chose en ce moment mais
au départ on disait je m'en bat l'oeil
et aujourd'hui d'ailleurs quand tu dis
je m'en bats les nouilles
sauf que c'est pas exactement ce qu'on
dit on te dit oh ouais tu peux être poli
et utiliser la vraie expression qui est
je m'en bat l'oeil alors que cette
expression là est bien pire
j'aime plus vulgaire elles datent du
xviie siècle et même jean de la fontaine
s'en sert dans un de ses textes
à cette époque l'oeil ça veut dire un
oeil mais c'est aussi une espèce de
métaphore d'un autre endroit du corps
c'est-à-dire l'anus donc à cette époque
l'oeil ça veut dire les deux mais dans
cette expression parle surtout d'en bas
et les expressions de cette époque qui
comporte le mot oeil veulent dire ça par
exemple se mettent le doigt dans l'oeil
ça date de la même époque et là tu le
vois un peu différemment déjà et par
extension tous les dérivés genre je m'en
tape le coquillard bay le coquillard tu
devines bien ce que c'est quoi voilà
donc la prochaine fois que quelqu'un de
dire je m'en bat l'oeil où tu te mets le
doigt dans l'oeil
tu lui demanderas d'être un petit peu
plus polis les petites vidéos rapide de
l'été c'est une fois tous les deux jours
jusqu'au 30 août si ça vous a plu vous
pouvez cliquer et puis cliquez et non
pas dans l'oeil mais ici là par là pour
vous abonner et toujours le même
planning une vidéo tous les deux jours
donc rendez vous après le match à eau